MALE SPEAKER: So
I actually think
I'd like to start first with a
question about Racepoint, which
you started in 2002.
And actually, I'll start
with another question.
Why did you decide
to write books?
And who are you writing for?
LARRY WEBER: The
first book that nobody
read, I wanted to write
about all the new technology
leaders I had been working with,
like Steve Jobs, Larry Ellison.
I had met Sergey and Larry,
but it was a little later.
It was like 2002 in Aspen.
But I was amazed
that these guys were
different than the corporate
leaders I had worked with,
and so I was just
observing the way they
were building companies.
And it was called
"The Provocateurs."
How a new generation of leaders
are building communities, not
just companies.
So it was that sort of angle,
and it was the late '90s.
And I just wanted to capture
all these people that I had met
and do that.
And then, I started realizing--
and this relates to Racepoint.
By the way, I
couldn't use my name.
My lawyer didn't tell me I
had sold my name to IPG too.
So that's why it's called
Racepoint Global, which
is after one of the oldest
lighthouses in America
off Provincetown.
But anyway, the
other books started
to seep in because I realized
technology obviously was going
to change marketing forever.
And it was the last category
that didn't even have an ERP
system, or enterprise system.
And then, I was also an early
stupid investor in Friendster,
and I knew that the
impact of social media
was going to be huge.
So I wanted to
write to marketers.
There wasn't CMO titles then.
But I wanted to write to
marketers and CEOs-- so
C-levels-- about the
coming vast changes
in reaching your customers.
And I thought social media
was the first huge computing
wave after HTML that was
going to have huge impact.
And so I wrote a
book that became
my biggest bestseller in 2006
called "Marketing to the Social
Web."
And it wasn't because
it was a great book.
I think it was because it
was the first book written
on that topic.
And then I also
learned something
about publishing, which
is that if you write
a more instructive
book and it's pretty
decent about a new
topic, all of a sudden
it's in the curriculum
of a bunch of schools
because we were trying to figure
out why the book would sell
so much in August and January.
And then we realized
it was everywhere
from Birmingham at the
University of Alabama
to Columbia.
And then, my favorite
book, the third book
I wrote in 2009, which had
a telling chapter in it,
which is one of the best books
I've ever written that nobody
read called "Sticks and Stones
about Digital Reputation"
in 2009.
And I had a chapter that
Harvard Business Review loved
called the YouTube Juggernaut.
And this was seven,
eight years ago.
I was thinking about
after I met Chad Hurley.
And even though he
was just having fun,
I saw a future where most
data and most content
was going to be
presented visually.
And that there would probably
more of a category of data
called visual information
versus just videography.
And I was playing
around with that idea,
so I thought that
would be a cool thing
to write about so I did that.
And this is a long answer
to a simple question.
I also figured out how to
write a book within six
to nine months.
You know, how to research
it, write it, have a helper.
I had two MBA
students do research,
then I had a ghost
writer who I'd finally
have given her credit so I'm
not a complete sexist ass.
Who would say, Larry,
you wrote that last week.
That's not another
chapter kind of thing.
And then, I drifted to a
bigger topic, which did OK,
the book before this one.
This is a bestseller
now, but that one
was called "Everywhere,"
and it was my view
that social media was not
just impacting marketing.
It was impacting
the way we did HR.
It was impacting the
way we did finance.
way we did sales.
So in "Everywhere," I was
trying to take a different,
and I think that
was a little early.
And this one seems
just about right,
and this one has its roots.
It's called "The
Digital Marketer-- 10
New Skills you Need to Know
to Stay Customer Centric."
It's about what I think
is today and the future
of marketing, which is
what "Racepoint" represents
is my idea of building the
Frankenstein of an agency.
And we can talk about that
Frankenstein in a good way.
You know, the perfection
kind of thing.
But this one was here because
of my publisher, Wiley,
of the last four books.
Random House was the first
one, but my publisher
said what's your next
marketing book, Larry?
And I said, well, let me see
what's out there right now.
So I went on Amazon and
I googled things too.
And I realized that what
is being written even today
is there's the
experts on search.
There's the experts on
marketing automation software.
There's the experts on content
creation and content strategy.
You name it, a slice.
But nobody I thought had written
a book like David Ogilvy's
"Ogilvy on Advertising" where
he sat back in 1965 and went,
OK, let's look at the entire
New Yorker map of marketing
and advertising and all that.
And it was a
brilliant landscape.
And so what this
book attempts to be
is let's look at the
entire digital landscape
of storm software to
search to visual to content
to a lot of software.
And then write about
that so that then you
can dig down instead
of drilling down first,
get sort of a thing.
So that's why I write.
And also, the last
reason I write
is it's really good
at getting business.
Because when my competitors
are giving business cards,
I'm handing out books.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'll ask one
or two quick follow-ups on that.
So in some regards,
you didn't even
anticipate who you were writing
for, like the college students,
for instance.
LARRY WEBER: I just got
interested in different topics.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
As it relates to it's
a good way to build
business or different types
of access and exposure,
specifically as it relates
to the college students,
how do you see colleges treating
this type of career path
differently, or do you?
Places where maybe
they've invited
you to talk after buying
lots of your books?
LARRY WEBER: Yeah, a lot of the
marketing, like San Jose State,
BU, and I think they're
finally getting it.
They're teaching a little
more around search,
around content strategies.
But I think the professors
are still caught up
in the operational world that
has the head of advertising
or the head of direct
marketing or the head of PR,
and they haven't completely
adopted the earned,
paid and owned media concept
of putting things together.
I think they're trying.
I think Columbia is really
trying hard, especially
in the journalism school.
To change the way we
view the way content
is produced and presented.
But one place that
they're missing
is this integration of
software, and I have not
seen that around
when I've talked.
And the kids get
afraid a little bit,
and I can't believe this
because most of these kids
are English majors that are
interested in the marketing.
Or history majors.
And I said, you've got to
understand basic coding.
You just have to.
You're just going to
have to force yourself.
It's like eating
spinach when you're 10
because you're going to have
to understand how to integrate
the best software tools
you have available to reach
your customers
directly, consistently,
and in an engaging way.
And I think we're
sort of at that period
that it's really hard
to bring that together.
But it's going to happen.
And the other thing I learned
about that, not from schools,
but was going to spend time--
I was on the board of a company
we sold to Marketo.
And so I went and spent
time with that CEO and CMO,
and then I spent time
with the Eloqua guys,
and then my friends at
HubSpot, Brian and Dharmesh.
They hate when I say
this, but we really
studied those products.
They're really very simple
and they're not very complex.
I don't mean they
need to be complex,
but I think they make mistakes.
They aren't integrated
properly necessarily
with Salesforce or other
advanced CRM systems,
these kinds of things.
So we're in this
world right now where
I really think it's like year
one of the new marketing, which
is going to, again, be
around data software,
but still creativity and
content and visualization.
And some schools are
starting to get that,
but again, it's a different
type of career path.
And I think what
the kids are looking
for are companies like
Google to help teach them
some of those things.
That they might get the
basics at these universities
around the basics of purchase
theory and pricing and things
that marketing and
sales should understand.
But that I want to go to
Amazon or Google or Facebook
because they can teach me more
about the future of things,
which, by the way, is not always
innovative, as I was telling
Sheryl Sandberg.
She thought native advertising
two years ago was just so cool.
I said, you know, Sheryl, we've
been doing that for 30 years.
We called it advertorials,
and we labeled it an ad.
So there's a lot of inventing
of things that's going on,
but what is changing is the
objectives of marketing.
I think it should be more
about engagement time
and less about the purchase
and more about the engagement.
You know, the shareability,
those kinds of things.
So, anyway.
MALE SPEAKER: So just as
a quick poll question--
LARRY WEBER: I could go on.
MALE SPEAKER: What's that?
LARRY WEBER: I just said
I could go on and on.
MALE SPEAKER: I know.
That's why you're here.
LARRY WEBER: Oh, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
why I didn't have
to write too many questions.
How many had a major that was
something like a liberal arts
major in this room?
And how many had
a business major?
LARRY WEBER: Computer science?
MALE SPEAKER: And how many
had a computer science
oriented major?
So weighted towards the--
LARRY WEBER: Well,
it's good that you're
all in the same room.
When I started 35 years
ago, IT was just beginning.
I mean, we look so different in
marketing versus the IT guys.
And then I remember
over the years
in Boston, all of a sudden there
were all these-- by the way,
there were only two C titles
when I started in business.
There was the CEO and the CFO.
And then all of a
sudden, this Fortune 500
company I was working
with had a COO,
and I was intrigued to see what
their responsibilities were.
I read the responsibilities, and
they seem like the same stuff
the CEO and the CFO
was supposed to do.
And anyway, I moved
here in early 1982,
and that's when I got
into technology marketing
because I mistakenly went
to a party-- or actually,
fortunately went
to a party and met
a barefoot guy named Mitch Kapor
who was starting a software
company called Lotus.
And we hit it off and introduced
most of their products.
But anyway, there were all these
titles back then called MIS.
I mean, some of the older people
must remember MIS-- managers
of information services.
And companies hired
so many of those
that they had another
C title-- CTOs.
And then all those people
started buying all the software
and the CTOs didn't
understand the software,
so they have a CIO.
And then we went through
this period in the '90s
where everybody was making
so much money that we decided
to have titles like
chief talent officer
and chief knowledge officer
and chief strategic officer.
And then in the 2000s, which
I think is fascinating,
is the fastest growing title in
corporate America, especially
a CMO.
And I think it's easy to
deduce then that every time we
have a really fucked up
category of business,
we just put a C title on it
to try to straighten it out.
And now it's so funny.
My clients right now range from
IBM, General Electric, Kaiser
Permanente, John Deere,
the Page Family Foundation,
emerging companies.
And I'm starting to see
CMO titles get thrown out
and we're having
the chief customer
office and the chief
engagement officer
and chief experience officer.
So we're definitely in
another C title Renaissance.
MALE SPEAKER: In no
particular order,
you mentioned the Page
Family Foundation.
That's Larry Page.
And I don't know if
you guys even know.
LARRY WEBER: Larry and Lucy.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
Larry and Lucy.
You guys might not even
know that kind of stuff
that family foundation
is involved with.
And it might just be
interesting for you to know.
Do you want to describe
what you're doing with them
and what their programs are?
LARRY WEBER: There's
two things I learned.
I should have known this
about Google in the beginning
because we had
also done some work
for 23andMe, and from the
other guy's former wife.
But just by nature
of Google, the CDC
was very interested in
searches in specific areas
about if all of a
sudden all of San Diego
goes off the charts
looking for flu symptoms,
then there's a connection
between you guys
and the CDC that
says, oh, my god,
you guys better check out the
health officials in San Diego
because the searches for
flu are just off the charts.
And so our San Francisco office
was approached by the Page
Family Foundation
because for some reason
Lucy and Larry had made a point
that we're worried about all
these diseases that might
affect one or two people,
yet like 40,000 people die
of complications of the flu
every year.
And it's avoidable if you get
your kid to have a flu shot,
but it turns out
that a lot of parents
don't trust the flu shot
and all this kind of stuff.
So they said let's try a sort
of experiment just in one city
urban area, and
they picked Oakland.
And so our creative team
came up with an idea
called "Shoe the Flu."
And it's a whole
educative through video.
We use traditional media, like
billboards in downtown Oakland,
television, that
kind of stuff, to try
to really ramp up the rate of
getting your kids vaccinated.
And it really works.
So we're in the planning stages
now of going sort of urban area
by urban area to
start to do that.
But they do a lot
more than that.
That's just one sort of example,
but it's also a great marketing
example because it's a
combination of search.
It's a usage of software,
of old-fashioned creative,
of video content, of education,
educational materials,
and those kinds of things.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
before I knew-- in fact,
I'm sure before I knew that,
A, the Page Foundation was
involved with that.
And B, you guys were
I had identified that
as a campaign that
used in several presentations
in as part of the feel,
think, do continuum
because it really
does a good job of addressing.
One of the models we use
for talking about consumer
experiences-- feel, think,
do, and loyalty or bond.
I thought then
and still think it
does a wonderful
job in the think
and do area because you enable
the parent to do research
and get comfortable with
the flu shot concept.
And then actually take it
to getting the shot itself.
So it actually then
directs them to a place
where they can get the shot.
So I use it in many
presentations as something
that fulfills the
think and do component.
Can we talk about Frankenstein
and what your hypothesis
or epiphany was to build a
different type of agency,
different type of company.
LARRY WEBER: One of
the problems I've
had being around this
long is the three
strands I was in back
in the early '80s
introducing software companies.
And then I was lucky
enough in 1992, 1993,
it was probably a very
seminal time for at least me
when we were invited.
Well, let me tell you
a story, and then I'll
get to Frankenstein.
We still do work
for the labs at MIT.
So we still represent
the Media Lab.
I have for 25 years both
at the previous company
and this company.
And for about 15 years,
we represented the lab
for computer science,
which arguably
is the one that
has really produced
the things that have changed.
I mean, ethernet, spreadsheet,
RSA security really
have changed a lot of things
and made Kendall Square so hot,
I think.
I was called up by the guy
that had started that, Michael
Dertouzos, who was a big
consultant to Bill Gates,
and was one of the founders
of Davos, the World Economic
Forum.
And he called because
he was mad that Nicholas
Negroponte-- who's a
wonderful man, a bit acerbic.
MALE SPEAKER: Tell
everyone who he is.
LARRY WEBER: He
founded the Media Lab,
and also One Laptop per
Child, which is very popular,
started from 2007.
It's still around in 2014.
He should get the Nobel
Prize, by the way,
not for the Media
Lab, but for bringing
the cost of computing
down in one fell swoop.
I mean, in 2007
when we introduced
the XO, which we named the
little green laptop, people
yelling at Nicholas
from Dell to HP to IBM
was still in the
business, Lenovo.
Because what forced their
hand was, hey, guys,
you can't get $2,000
for a laptop anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: He was delivering
laptops to kids in Africa
for less than $100
apiece, right?
LARRY WEBER: We
didn't get below $100.
We got to about $148
or something like that.
And obviously now,
eventually, you
should be able it free just like
there'll be free smartphones.
Which definitely will
happen in your lifetime.
The devices will mostly be free.
That's why Apple's
becoming a fashion company,
and to me, now, the technology
company as much anymore.
Even though their software is
what got them here, you know?
But to finish that story,
Michael had come over
and he brought a videotape.
Who brings a videotape to
a meeting anymore, right?
And he brought a little
British man with him
that had just joined
his organization.
Right here, he's still here
at that Ray Stata building,
the weird Frank Gehry
building that still leaks.
But anyway, his name
was Tim Berners-Lee.
And so Tim sat
there very quietly.
He had brought his
experiment or his research
called HTML to the lab
for computer science
and he, by the way, called
it the World Wide Web.
He asked if that was
catchy, but anyway.
But Michael puts in
this video and it
was him on-- are you familiar
with the "Today Show" on NBC?
I ask because my 25-year-old
and 22-year-old daughters
have no idea what
the "Today Show" is.
Anyway, so it was
on the occasion.
He had written a big
bestseller, Michael,
with a guy who still teaches
here at 89 years old,
Nobel Prize winner for
economics in 1997, Robert Solow.
And they wrote a book together
called "Made in America"
in 1981, and that's why he
was on the "Today Show."
And it was of 12 years earlier.
A guy named Bryant
Gumbel was the main host.
He's on television
a little bit still,
and his brother's sports.
But he starting
to interview him.
And the book, by the
way, it was a time,
the older people will remember,
when our economy really sucked
and the Germans and the Japanese
were really eating our lunch.
And the main reason was
they had new factories
and we didn't, but nobody
talked about that at the time.
But this book,
"Made in America,"
argued that you should all
just chill because America
has one thing that no
other country has-- Germany
and Japan, and they weren't
really looking at China
at the time because it was still
sort of disorganized there.
But it was this thing
called software,
and that we had the ability
to use creativity and computer
technology to actually
create so many things that
would lead to economic
prosperity for decades
and decades to come.
And so he's talking about
this on this TV show,
and the IBM PC had
just been launched too.
And those old enough to
remember was the first time
there were ads on television.
They used a Charlie Chaplin look
alike who was stacking boxes
and was actually a very popular
advertisement at the time.
And what happened was Bryant
Gumbel looks over and says,
now, this PC kind of thing.
This is just a fad, right?
This is all going to go away.
And Professor Dertouzos leans
over the interview table
and goes not only is it
not going to go away,
but within 20 years,
everyone will have
one of these on their desk.
And they will be buying
and selling things,
and they'll be
sharing information,
and we'll be learning
from these machine.
And he was describing
what has happened.
And Bryant Gumbel says we
have to cut to a commercial
because this is crazy.
So I only bring that up
because then the background
of understanding and launching
HTML and the World Wide Web
consortium.
Understanding marketing and
telling technology stories
for software companies
and technology companies.
And then understanding
the media were all
starting to come together.
And then I was stupid enough to
sell a company growing at 50%
a year in 1996-97 97 to mad men,
and they really were "Mad Me."
I mean, at 5 o'clock they
started with the Martinis right
in the office.
And I won't go into
the other stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: What's
your next book?
LARRY WEBER: My
wife said to retire
before I write the
book of working
with everybody from Steve
Jobs to Muammar Gaddafi,
so what an odd career.
Well, first of all,
I sold too early.
But that's OK.
I got to spend seven
years on Madison Avenue
and help them buy their
first digital agency.
They didn't even
know what that was.
One was called RGA, that
has flourished quite well.
I'm sure you guys worked with.
And I built Weber
Shandwick, then
I bought 31 companies
around the world.
But what I was learning
was what I've always
tried to see is what the
vision of the perfect marketing
service company would be because
the agency world was going
to change was my determination.
It can't depend on television
commercials forever.
Now, again, I thought television
was going to die much earlier.
And have you
noticed, by the way,
my ADD medicine's
not kicking in,
but have you
noticed that there's
more live events on television
than there's ever been?
And you know why that is, right?
It's much harder to get rid of
a commercial on live events.
And so all the
big TV companies--
I mean, the NBCs,
the CBSes-- they're
all looking for more
that they can present.
So that's why they're trying
to get European soccer to have
a following and
more reality shows
so that you can't
delete that commercial.
But back to Frankenstein--
so I learned all the way
through all of this.
Through technology,
having the largest office
in Palo Alto of any
PR firm for years,
watching the failures of
startup companies and that.
And by the time my earn-out was
over, I stayed two more years
and I said, you know what?
There's got to be a
different model for this.
And I made the mistake of
saying, all right, what
I'm going to do is
my folding company,
I'm going to have what's
next in every category
and only digitized.
So what's next in advertising?
What's next in direct?
What's next in
data and analytics?
What's next in PR?
And they're all going
to have separate names
and we're all going to
be one big happy family
and we're going
to be the future.
And I realized that
after 2008 came,
nobody wanted to buy old
stuff let alone new stuff,
and that was really tough.
So I went through
three years of it.
It was just terrible.
And finally, IBM and
General Electric and Kaiser
all about the same time
said, you know, Larry?
Your ideas are right,
but they should all
be integrated and put together.
And this should be
one agency offering.
It shouldn't just be.
And so that's when we started
to really integrate everything.
But we have to lead
with a point of view,
and that's what I
call earned media,
which is a fancy name for PR.
So how do you get
covered in the blogs?
How do you get
covered on TechCrunch?
How do you get covered
in wallstreetjournal.com,
forbes.com, all
that kind of stuff.
But we quickly move then
to a creative department,
a technology department.
We've developed two software
products around influence
so that we could identify the
100 most influential people
to a specific
company or a product
and what are their
social properties?
So we know what
one reporter really
likes to tweet, another
one doesn't, who
their friends are on Facebook,
et cetera, kind of things.
So we're really working deeply
from an influence perspective,
and then I argue that
the future of an agency
is going to be about a new
solar system model where
the sun-- if you take
this metaphor-- the sun is
the customer and all the
planets going around it
are things like marketing
automation, software, content,
visualization, data
analytics, all that.
And some of those are all going
to collide and become together
kinds of things.
But it's going to be an
interesting time right now.
There's a reason that there
wasn't a marketing ERP system
and every other
category had one.
HR was PeopleSoft, finance
was SAP, database was Oracle.
You can go down the line.
And I think the reason
is, one, Madison Avenue
Mafia, and London and
Paris now, who are trying
to keep television alive.
And how they're going to do that
is combining more with you guys
and doing as much as they
can to prop up the media
spends that they have.
But my view is
that there's going
to be an alignment
of consulting,
of creative technology
of software.
Deloitte, for example,
bunch of accountants
just bought a San
Francisco digital agency.
Interesting to me that they
now could do everything
from conceptual consulting,
much like a Bain
or a BCG, all the way through
execution of a campaign,
digitally.
And then we see competitors
from any given day,
Sapient and Digitas to Ogilvy
is a big competitor of ours now,
to the big PR firms, who
are actually really lagging
still because PR is
still a category that
waits for stuff to
happen and then reacts
versus being very aggressive
about making things happen,
which is more the paid
side of the world.
And so, it's been a
fascinating time right now.
But I think that
the next five years
are going to be interesting
in this convergence,
and I think
companies like Google
are right at the heart of this.
As one of the sumo wrestlers
for the heart and soul
of the future of the web.
And I don't know if you seen
the tech or the Venture Beat
article last week on
the era of messaging?
Has anybody seen that?
I recommend looking
at that article
as it will impact your business.
And I thought they
want a little too far.
That messaging is going
to be so explosive
and that's going to be a new
advertising model and marketing
model, but it's another
play in the thing.
I'm on the board of the largest
social network in Africa.
It's called MIXT-- M-I-X-T-- and
it's a feature phone kind of.
So more like a WhatsApp
for Africa kind of thing.
And it's interesting to see the
different uses of messaging.
I'm sure you guys are
studying this completely.
But in this last book, I talk a
lot about if I was a young kid
and I was interested
in marketing,
I'd get into loyalty,
digital loyalty or couponing.
I think that is still
in the dark ages,
and how that's going
to happen contextually.
I'll give you an example.
I was on a panel with Howard
Schultz two years ago,
a year and a half
ago in Washington.
And after, we were all talking
afterwards, and he said,
would you be a guinea
pig for a marketing thing
we're trying to
do with Starbucks?
And I said, OK, sure.
And I didn't hear anything from
him or anybody from Starbucks.
But about a month
later, I get an email
to introduce the person in
the marketing department
at Starbucks and said thanks
for agreeing to do this test
program with us.
And would you fill out
this sort of survey.
It was like SurveyMonkey,
only customized to Starbucks.
And it asked me questions
like when you go to Starbucks,
what time usually is it?
What's your favorite
thing you order?
If you order food,
what food do you order?
Do you buy for your
family or other people,
or is it pretty much, so
does somebody buy for you?
And so they were asking
some pretty good questions
even though it was only about
eight to nine questions.
And then would you give
us your cellphone number,
and I said sure.
By the way, I'm from the Scott
McNealy school of privacy.
I don't believe
it exists anymore.
I'm OK with it, except
in the future I think--
MALE SPEAKER: You're
going to have to tell
everyone who Scott McNealy is.
LARRY WEBER: Oh, he
was one of the founders
of Sun Microsystems that
was bought by Oracle.
And they had the software, Java
was one of their big software
platforms.
Anybody uses Java anymore?
But anyway, he also
said privacy is dead.
Get over it.
But I do think it's going to
be an important discussion
around health data.
But I don't care
if somebody knows I
like pink shirts
from Brooks Brothers.
I really don't.
In fact, it should
work in my advantage
that somebody knows
that kind of thing.
To finish the Starbucks story,
so I forgot about it again
because they didn't do anything.
I didn't get any
offers or anything.
So I'm with my middle
daughter in London.
She had some time
off-- or no, I know.
She was doing one of those
junior year things in Edinburgh
and I had her come down
to London to see a show.
And so we were waking up
at the hotel and I said,
well, let's go get some
breakfast somewhere.
And right when I
said that-- that was,
I'm sure, coincidental-- I
get a text from Starbucks.
And it's says--
MALE SPEAKER: All of
that was coincidental?
LARRY WEBER: Yeah,
I say, Hi, Larry.
It says, hi, Larry.
Why don't you come
across the street
to 325 Kensington High Street
for your free iced espresso,
and we'll give you 25 pounds
off your breakfast sandwich.
And I went, Julia,
let's go over there.
I think this is cool.
Julia being a 21-year-old coed
at one of those fancy schools
that costs too much said,
Dad, that's sort of creepy.
They could have sent
a drone on top of you.
I'm like, well, now let's
go see if this works.
So we went in and
I said I think I
have a free iced
espresso and some money
off a breakfast sandwich.
And she says, OK, I
haven't seen that before.
But you know, so I held
it up and it goes through.
And so I get it and I
thought that was pretty cool.
And then I started
thinking about all that
must have had to go into that.
And I started
thinking about things
like contextual marketing, and
predictive analytics, which
are going to be the
two of the biggest
areas in the next few years.
And I was thinking, well,
what if they offered me
like an iced herbal tea
and I hate herbal tea?
And they would have
set the relationship
back a little with me, even
though it was a free offer.
So that's what I mean
about the complexity
in the future of this
sort of digital loyalty
and points and programming.
And then I was
trying to use points
to go down to see a college with
my youngest son the other day.
And it was such
a pain in the ass
to try to use my
delta points still.
And I'm like, who's going
to come up with-- just,
it is so easy.
Mr. Weber, you have
900,000 points,
and I still had to pay
full price for my ticket.
And I was like, my god,
this is just insane.
I should be able to just
hold up that smartphone.
You guys organize it-- you,
Delta, or I'm going to JetBlue.
You organize it.
I don't want to
have numbers, cards.
I don't want any of that.
You also hit a loyalty
nerve with me there.
MALE SPEAKER: I had exactly the
same conversation with somebody
maybe in this room,
but certainly someone
here at Google in the last
week about United and exactly
the same conversation.
It was painful That was
a painful experience.
Does anyone have any
questions for Larry?
OK, good, because I have
more, but I should shut up.
LARRY WEBER: Is this OK?
Is this making
sense for you guys?
OK.
I can answer things about
the future of search,
too, if you want.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Larry.
Thanks for being here.
Quick question.
It's more of a hypothetical
desert island scenario.
If you were taken out of your
current position and said,
OK, you have to start a
widget company from scratch,
limited budget,
what's your hierarchy
of needs for techniques?
Because when we're
talking to clients
and they think this
omnichannel, they're
often having a conversation
with us as, OK, search, display.
They start talking
about things and what
they think the opportunity
cost of this dollar spent
here or that.
And then they start
thinking, well,
does PR give us SEO benefit?
Does this happen?
We have limited people.
We have limited money.
So if I put you in
a scenario where
you are supposed to build
a brand from scratch
and you don't have any of
your current resources,
how do you go about
building that plan?
LARRY WEBER: Yeah,
that's easy for me.
Good question.
I am not a big
believer in quant,
So that makes me pitted against
a lot of people right away.
Because they want quant.
They want massive
reach to customers
and they want it
right away and they
want startups to scale
right away, and this.
What I would argue to build
a great lasting brand today,
and I talk with Reid Hoffman
about this all the time.
He thinks LinkedIn will
last for a hundred years,
and that's what
they're trying to do.
And I think it'll be replaced
just like Monster was.
But anyway, what I
would do is I would
have strategies,
marketing strategies,
around engaging customers.
And I would measure the
length of engagement,
the content that's working,
the content that's not working,
and I would enlist listen
as the sales people.
How do you create a brand
around some kind of passion?
And I think even old companies
can reinvent that way.
One of the coolest
assignments we have right now,
which took nine
months of fighting
against the heads of marketing.
There's a company
called John Deere,
and I was having a
drink with its CEO
who said to me after two drinks.
He said, Larry, I don't know
what my legacy's going to be.
I don't want it to be that I
just sold more green tractors.
And so we started
talking about this,
and there's a reason
I'm bringing this up.
Because it can be
done for startups too.
And I said, well, let's see.
Let's look at the facts
about where you live.
You're a $50 billion
company and you're
collecting more farm data than
anybody on the planet, right?
And his assistant or
one of his sidekicks
was quoting these numbers so I
could get a picture in my head.
That when I was a kid, there
were 22,000 farms in America.
Today, there's 8,000 farms, but
they're are three times as big
and they're also
really complicated
on whether soil
content, fertilizer.
I mean, you name the data that
is needed to manage a farm.
And then they started talking
about their peer group,
and that their peer group
is Caterpillar and Kubota.
And then somebody
mentioned too that there's
going to be two billion more
people that have to be fed
and we can't ruin the planet.
How do we have a better yield
and how do we sort of do
good and that kind of stuff.
And so we went back
with a program that
said forget your peers are
Caterpillar and Kubota.
Just forget it.
Your peers are Google,
Amazon, and Apple, John Deere.
And of course, they looked
at me like I had three heads
because they're like, no.
We don't understand.
We don't compete with Amazon.
I said, it's not
about competition.
It's how you approach the way
and the work that you're doing,
and how you're going to
be innovative about this.
They had so much software
that they had developed
to help manage farms and data.
And so we're now working on this
huge program about how they're
not really about the tractors.
Yes they are.
But they're about feeding
the next $2 billion people
and they're about helping
manage farms smarter and better
and more effectively.
And this led me to
a marketing theory,
even for smaller
companies, that you know
what is going to happen now?
And this is a really
scary prediction.
I actually think big
software companies
are going to fail long term.
I think you're going to
see Oracle and SAP-- I
think these companies are
going to have a lot of trouble.
And I think what's
going to happen
is you're going to see GM,
John Deere, they're hiring
more and more developers.
They're customizing
more and more software.
They're managing more
data and analytics,
and they're engaging customers
with important decision making
tools.
And I think Google has got
to sit in the middle of that,
but I also think that's where
your marketing strategy has
to go.
So there's a company
spinning out.
You guys must know this
company spinning out
of MIT called Ditto.
And they have a
really cool technology
around analyzing
videos and photographs.
They know where you bought
that shirt by analyzing it
on Facebook or Instagram.
Now don't ask me how they
can do that one, all right?
But same thing.
How do you both start
to get that message out
to marketers and
to the customers
that they want in a more
educated way, not in
an in your face way.
And how do you create engagement
and content strategies
and things like that?
And then on the earned
media site when you said PR,
I still think that
carries a lot of weight.
Look at TripAdvisor alone.
I was talking to the CEO.
It looks like you're going to
be sued by the country of Mexico
because there's so many
bad reviews of the beaches
and the resorts in Mexico
that the government feels
that their businesses there
have lost like $4 billion or $5
billion and they're
blaming TripAdvisor.
Of course, I would
just say, well,
make the beach nicer, right?
Make me a stronger drink
or something like that.
But a part of what
is also wasted--
and I wish Google would
spend time on this too,
or somebody would-- is
we don't have the metrics
in this new generation
of marketing
that the '60s, '70s,
'80s, or the "Mad Men"
had with CPMs and all that.
They were so good at
bullshitting the client on what
was really measurable.
And we don't have that.
Nobody's grabbing
the baton and saying
is engagement time import?
Is a share index important?
Nobody talks about
organic search anymore.
We were talking
about it at lunch.
How important that is.
It's not just the paid search.
It's, gee, I googled
20 times today,
and I got the
information I want.
Or I did make a purchase with
the small company I've never
worked with before,
and that kind of thing.
So anyway, I think there's
a whole metric world that
hasn't been brought together.
That's a long answer, too.
But we're paying
bloggers more and more,
so that's another strategy
that I think is interesting.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
LARRY WEBER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you were talking
about the Frankenstein agency
and how everything is
going to be integrated
and talking to each other.
Can you share how you think
mobile is going to affect that?
What's going to be the
tipping point for mobile?
And when you think companies are
going to actually start caring?
LARRY WEBER: Yeah.
Well, first, I come
from the school
that there's no such
thing as mobile.
So I think just
everything is mobile.
You can take anything
anywhere, I guess.
I think companies want, again,
to see that metric result.
That if they're doing
loyalty programs,
like Starbucks
was testing on me,
they want to see that that's
really working from a loyalty
perspective.
So I think there's a real
measurement thing to mobile
around.
I don't think it's
around banners.
I don't think it's around
that kind of mobile marketing.
I think it's going to be about
community building, engagement,
messaging I think is
going to be important.
Couponing, loyalty, all
those kinds of stuff.
And some companies
are really getting it.
I mean, business to business
companies aren't as much yet.
But Deere is using
mobile apps to show
how you can get better yield.
So you have to show
both the information
and the data side as
well as the sales side
in some of these kinds
of efforts are stories.
But I think obviously
everything's
going to be a smartphone driven.
I'm not sure about the watch.
Is that coming out this week?
I'm just not sure if
that's just a paradigm
trying to make an
old paradigm better.
I just don't know.
I definitely wouldn't
pay $17,000 for a watch,
but I think the more
senior people that
come to me are they're
looking for brand engagement.
How are we going
to engage audiences
for a long period of time?
So I'm less in the
transaction business
and more in the engagement
and brand engagement business.
Because I think brand is
defined as the conversation
you have with your customer.
The weaker the conversation,
the weaker your brand is.
The stronger the conversation,
the stronger your brand.
Of course there's a
quant side to everything.
How are we going to
sell more orange juice?
And I think all the
analytic companies,
we may have way
too many of them,
but I think they're working hard
on all that kind of software
to do to deal with that.
And there's more mobile
software kinds of things.
But for Facebook to spend $22
billion dollars for WhatsApp,
I mean, that tells you they
see some vision of advertising
in messaging, or else
they're just stupid.
I don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone else?
I have another one
if no one-- OK.
Larry, you talk to,
obviously, senior executives
at a wide variety of
companies and company types.
What do you hear about Google?
What do senior executives
say about Google
from a macro
perspective if they do,
and what do they think their
relationship with Google
should be?
LARRY WEBER: I think if they
understand Google at all,
there's very much from
a search point of view
and a page search point of view.
They realize there's sort
of a real basic elder
or a mythic value to Google.
So obviously, you've
won the search.
At least searches that
exists today, you've won that
and we need to
spend money in that.
Because if I make hot,
red convertibles at Ford
and I'm in charge
of marketing that,
I better own sexy,
hot, red convertible.
The best price for
that kind of thing.
I think they get that.
I think some of the
things they don't get
is why is Google
trying everything?
Like why, you know?
What is really this
Internet of Things?
And why do they want
a driverless car?
And why are they in
looking at health care?
And what are the glasses about?
How is this going to impact me,
my brand, and what we're doing?
And I think to
remain an innovator,
you have to do that stuff.
But I think the
clarity of how you're
going to help big brands
I think can be better.
I think right now, it's more
on that paid search level
and more in the era when
most people wake up and go
to your landing page before
anything else and something.
How does that help me
at IBM, or how does it
help me at John Deere.
And I think that needs to
more corporate understanding
of brand versus just
the tactical work.
But I think they respect Google.
I think the smarter
conversations
I have, like, who do you think
the two or three people that
might win this
sort of everything
from Internet of Things to
the next wave of computing,
mobility, and all that.
And I constantly say
it's the two biggest sumo
wrestlers in my opinion
are Amazon and Google.
The last time I saw Bezos
being interviewed out
at one of those highfalutin
Techonomy kind of things.
The interviewer
said, how does it
feel to be one of the greatest
retailers of all time?
And he looked
physically disturbed.
And he wears this baseball
hat now really low.
And he goes, I am
not a retailer.
And the interviewer went,
OK, but what are you?
He goes, I'm the biggest
sucker of data on the planet.
That's what he said.
And so to show more, I think,
the positioning of Google,
how you are the next
generation of data collection
and how you use that to
create better brands,
I think it is an important
juncture right now.
By the way, I don't think
Apple's in that race
or that conversation.
I think Facebook
is questionable.
And maybe there's a new company.
There's always a new company,
but it's not Dropbox or Box.
Twitter should have been
more video and visual.
So there's probably
a startup that's
trying to play with
co-creation of visuals
or real-time sharing.
Snapchat is interesting.
It's getting into ads.
And Instagram still is
growing quite a bit,
so it seems to be
a bit of a model.
But again, I don't see the
impact that a Google has had.
The couple times I've
met your founders early
in their careers, just
refreshing young men
at the time, really, just
trying to figure out how they
could move the world ahead.
And I think they really
meant that they wanted Google
to be a really good company.
And I don't think people get
that sense as much that you've
gotten so big.
What do you do that's good?
What do you do as a good company
for the planet, for people?
MALE SPEAKER: I think that's
a good place to stop, then.
Thank you, Larry.
Thanks very much for joining us.
LARRY WEBER: Yeah.
Thanks.